well good evening from London welcome to
Piers Morgan on censored today Harry and
Megan torched what little was left of
their relationship with the royal family
and what little was left frankly of
their own reputations last week was
mostly sycophantic this latest
installment was downright seditious
well Harry and Megan's Netflix series
released to the world this morning is
packed with well not really Revelations
are they sort of rehashed old
Revelations with a new twist as it turns
out we've apparently been wrong all
along Britain is a nasty racist hell
hole where only magnificent Megan stood
up to all this and the world's biggest
victims are not the people of Ukraine or
the people battling covid or people
struggling in a devastating cost of
living crisis no the world's biggest
victims right now are the Duke and
Duchess of Netflix and don't take my
word for it
This Promise
of once you're married don't worry it'll
get better
once they get used to you it'll get
better
it of course will get better
but truth be told no matter how hard I
tried no matter how good I was
no matter what I did
they were still going to find a way
to destroy me
yeah nobody set out to destroy you you
destroyed yourselves in this country
with your ludicrous hypocritical
Behavior the truth be told what she just
said is completely not a garbage Harry
and Megan's romance engagement and
marriage were all good with ecstatic Joy
by the British media the public and the
royal family that they've all now
abandoned that's the truth not Harry and
Megan's truth but the actual truth the
first three hours of this Netflix series
paint a very different far uglier
picture of this country and our royal
family
eight days after the relationship became
public I put out a statement calling out
the racist undertones of Articles and
headlines that were written by the
British press I wasn't thinking about
how race played a part in any of this I
genuinely didn't think about it some of
the members of family was like right but
my wife had to go through that so why
should your girlfriend be treated any
differently why should you get special
treatment why should she be protected
and I said the difference here is the
race element I sometimes call the
Commonwealth for Empire 2.0 because that
is what it is there is a huge level of
unconscious bias the thing with
unconscious bias is it's actually no
one's fault but once it's been pointed
out or identified within yourself
you then need to make it right
yep we're all racist apparently
sounds like a different country but
let's be clear Britain's one of the most
tolerant and Multicultural nations in
the world we celebrated the Glamorous
modern Flair of neon Royals we eulogize
the newly biracial monarchies the fresh
face of 21st century Britain I wrote
newspaper columns about it myself
including on the day of the wedding the
press and public only turned on Harry
and Megan when their behavior became
obnoxious self-serving and rankedly
hypocritical sadly millions of people
around the world will watch this series
and they'll believe it they'll believe
the smears about Britain and our
monarchy that we're a bunch of bigoted
and hateful people they even blamed
brexit for the racism which apparently
was aimed at Meghan Markle which is just
completely absurd but by far the most
sickening part of this show for me was
the constant use of Harry's late mother
Princess Diana to stoke sympathy for
Megan
so much of what Megan is and how she is
so similar to my mum
she has the same compassion she has the
same empathy she has the same confidence
she has this warmth about her
I accept that there will be people
around the world who fundamentally
disagree with what I've done and how
I've done it
but I knew that I had to do everything I
could to protect my family grandma
nothing says protecting your family like
putting a kids in a reality TV series
does it
having known both women Princess Diana
and Meghan Markle you can say with
absolute certainty they're nothing in
common whatsoever I couldn't think of
two women more different when it comes
to compassion and empathy where's
Megan's been for her own father she
completely disowned him as she did all
her wedding actually before the wedding
as the series makes clear
he just suffered a stroke a few months
ago
Miss compassion hasn't even bothered to
call her father to ask how he is and the
answer is we'll find out tonight from
his son Thomas is he's not well at all
Harry's never even met the man whose
daughter he married doesn't care Mr
empathy Mr compassion
yet this man Thomas Markle raised Megan
on his own for many years that wasn't in
the documentary that was glossed over
that was ignored
just like he is now he lives 70 miles
away from them it's about an hour long
cab ride never seen his Grand
grandchildren this show is packed with a
kind of spurious
claims and hypocrisy to become a Sussex
signature we learned they began making
videos about the heroic Journey six
months before my Netflix deal was even
announced and right at the start of a
pandemic it was killing thousands of
people every day their only concern was
their own situation
so we had to flee the country for family
privacy says Harry as we watch a hundred
million dollar documentary when she
flaunts his young children and shares
private text messages intimate
photographs for the entire world to see
when it comes to Paparazzi I have more
Paparazzi outside my house when I was
forced to leave my old job a
disbelieving princess Pinocchio's lies
then I saw actually outside their houses
at any stage of this documentary
maybe their mob scenes are to come we
haven't seen any so far that all their
claims of Paparazzi intrusion in the two
trailers turned out to be nothing to do
with them they weren't even at many of
the events which were depicted
so forgive me if I don't think this is
all a load of BS
but frankly the biggest problem with
this series so far is that like the
Sussex themselves is actually it's dull
it's predictable it's cliche ridden it's
simperingly sycophantic it's one
long-rendition of all their greatest
whinges and a lot of self-congratulatory
nonsense Harry and Megan sold their
Royal souls to become reality TV stars
but they've got the Charisma to carry
their own sob story they're not grasping
ex-royal version of the Kardashians only
with less class less loyalty and less
brains Harry and Megan
dreariest couple in the history of
planet Earth
famously abandoned their Royal duties
for a life of privacy they left the
Goldfish bowl of Great Britain for the
camouflage of California remember
famously sheltered from the evil British
press and since then they've kept an
incredibly low profile as they vowed to
if you excuse the massive book deals the
Silicon Valley startups the preaching
videos about well-being the podcast the
speeches and the major Network
interviews with everyone from Oprah
Winfrey to James Corden but they've
barely been seen or heard at all have
they well on Thursday they'll quietly
and apologetically released their 100
million dollar documentary series on
Netflix I mean nothing says protecting
your family like doing a reality TV fly
on the ball documentary about every
aspect of your family life for the
delectation of the entire planet does it
Harry well the brain pack of Paparazzi
photographers jostling the space to
Hound the happy couple that's what we
just saw right childhood photographs
clearly intended to evoke the tragic
death of his mother Diana
both photographers we just saw weren't
actually interested in Prince Harry at
all they were at the premiere of a Harry
Potter movie five years before Harry
even met Megan there weren't any Royals
there at all
there's apparently sneaky paparazzo
lurking above the sussexes was actually
invited there to cover their meeting
with Archbishop tutu in Cape Town
another photo used in the promotions
shows Harry's outstretched hand
apparently shielding the couple from
photographers only it's actually a
cropped photo of Harry with
ex-girlfriend Chelsea Davey taken in
2007 and a press scrum shown dashing
after the unhappy couple was actually
chasing after reality TV stuff one of
their compatriots now Katie Price at
Crawley magistrates Court
ironically for a couple of repeatedly
sued newspapers for intrusion and
inaccuracy
they've just put a lot of Whoppers into
their trailers that's before we even get
to the main event
when the stakes were this high
doesn't it make more sense to hear our
story from us
oh shut up
what do you mean the stakes of this hire
Do You Think You Are
other than latte munching
imbecile living in luxury in California
while the rest of the world is the cost
of living crisis moaning and whining
about institution which gave you the
titles on which you now trade millions
of dollars
when you're talking about Stakes are
there other than the massive gigantic
stake you're currently plunging into our
monarchy over here
and as for telling their story sorry if
I missed something I thought you've been
telling your truth which is often a pack
of lies from the moment you abandon this
country
well today's new trailer doubles down on
the last trailer and there's more tears
remember that clip of Megan wants
showing us how she could cry like that
at the drop of a little teeny tarnished
Tiara remember that she could do it like
that
just bear that in mind when you watch it
did you get that one
a shameful comparisons for Princess
Diana
I remember Prince Harry being very very
angry about the media exploiting his
mother for commercial game yeah what has
he done with this Netflix series he's
used his mother to sell it
could there be a more grotesque
exploitation or a more hypocritical one
than him using his Dead Mother's imagery
to engender sympathy for himself again
as the great victim in this world
I find it all puke making
and I speak of someone who was actually
in one of these things I pop up
yeah me
um and to my astonishment I was being
very nice about Meghan Markle
let's have a listen
it's really hard to look back on it now
and go what on Earth happened
[Applause]
[Music]
everything changed there's a hierarchy
of the family you know there's leaking
but there's also planting of stories
there was a war against Megan to suit
other people's agendas it's about hatred
it's about race it's a dirty game
and suffering of women marrying into
this institution this feeling Frenzy
I realized they're never going to
protect you
I was terrified I didn't want history to
repeat itself
[Music]
no one knows the full truth
we know the full truth
oh God you wouldn't know the truth if it
hit you around the back of your head
this gruesome twosome only survived by
cashing in on what's left of their Royal
status now
I said it before I'll say it again
tonight King Charles just strip them all
their remaining titles and cast them out
from any connection to the royal family
and he often trusts them as far as I
could throw them because without it
they're just whining Millennial windbags
with a permanent victim complex knowing
that victim mode is what makes them all
the money the irony is earth-shattering
isn't it Harry and Megan are the Duke
and Duchess of gaslighting themselves
the entire show is a cynical attempt to
manipulate viewers into questioning
their own Recollections of reality
and if we learned anything at all from
the first three hours of this hundred
million dollar wine-a-thon it's surely
that this dismal Duo wouldn't know the
truth if he smack them around their smug
chops let's look at their Truth versus
the actual truth
Mega moans at Royal advisors forced her
to uninvite her dear niece Ashley from
the wedding the only member of her
family that she seemed to be still
talking to
how do we explain that this half-sister
isn't invited to the wedding but that
the half-sister's daughter is
so with Ashley the guidance at the time
was to not have her come to our wedding
yeah that was a lie
that could be placed Royal sources told
the Sunday Times no such guidance was
ever given
and that was supposed to be the show's
big example of how Megan really cares
very deeply about her family so deeply
that only one member of that family was
at the wedding her mother not even her
favorite little niece Ashley
Megan also sees she got no advice on
Royal protocol forcing her to learn how
to be a princess all on her own
joining this family I knew that there
was a protocol for how things were done
there's no class and some person who
goes sit like this cross your legs like
this use this Fork don't do this curtsy
then wear this kind of hat it doesn't
happen
another lie and by the way Megan if you
don't like me calling you a liar just
sue me and we'll go through all this in
court
there's suddenly times discovered she
was actually handed a 30-point dossier
studiosity research brimming with
information and contacts
Megan led to simpas that she never wore
bright colors to show respect because
she's all about respect
so I was like well what's a color that
they'll probably never wear
camel beige white so I wore a lot of
muted tones but it also was
so I could just blend in
like I'm not trying to stand out here
no the last thing Mega mark would ever
want to do is stand up but it's all one
other live photos taken by the evil
bigoted British press show her wearing
pretty much every color in the rainbow
the show opens with a claim that they're
all family declined to comment on the
series that's another lie the palace
says it received one email from an
unknown company and attempts to verify
it were flatly ignored even the story of
their romance and engagement turns out
to be in a series of Whoppers they told
the BBC in 2017 they were set up by a
mutual friend on a blind date they told
Netflix they met on Instagram and what
about Harry's Modest Proposal in their
humble cottage kitchen
uh it happened a few weeks ago
um earlier this month here at our
Cottage
um it's a standard typical night for us
cozy night it was
redoing just roasting chicken and having
Chinese chicken and it was just
an amazing surprise it was so sweet an
amazing surprise it was so sweet well
according to Netflix which is their show
it was actually a candle Extravaganza in
their Walled Garden
and Megan was so amazingly surprised she
managed to figure out what was happening
and tell her friend about it before
Harry even popped the question
small little detail but rather like
their claim or Megan's claim that they'd
been secretly married by the Archbishop
of Canterbury in their Garden before
three days before the big televised
wedding which also turned out not just
to be untrue but had it been true would
have led to the Archbishop of
accountability being incarcerated in
prison
as with all things Megan and Harry it
would seem the truth just doesn't really
exist in their world it's their truth
their version of it
yeah look at the front pages there which
is when their engagement was announced
where's the racism
do you remember that was before she
actually said that the institution was
racist and that's my point how
institutionalized racism works is the
Ministries
sorry for just everyone's chanting
that's what happens you accept there's
no racism in those media Pages because
that was before she said that the
institution was racist actually
that's when everyone decided to Pilot
actually what happened as a woman people
began to pile on when she started having
half a million dollar baby showers in
New York and flying back on the Clooney
private plane they started having a
pylon
when they used Elton John's private
plane like a taxi rank whilst preaching
about carbon footprint they had another
pile on where they had other huge
extravagant events they went to and then
when they're preaching about poverty on
their Twitter account time and again
they were caught being rankly
hypocritical that was why the media
coverage began to turn then there was
all the stuff with her father many
people felt that she was unnecessarily
cruel to her father people have since
criticized his own behavior I accept
that but certainly to start with they
ditched him they dropped him Harry's
never met his his father-in-law in his
life
you know he proposed marriage to this
girl knowing what's going to happen and
then doesn't do anything to protect the
father at all and so now she's disowned
him what kind of people but compassion
on their website as they do as being at
the center of their core being when they
live 70 miles away from this guy who has
not got long for this world is in poor
health all he wants to do is meet his
grandchildren and she won't have
anything to do with it that's not
compassionate
and also the hypocrisy and the lies are
not what I think are decent values in
people and I think Meghan Markle
branding is a racist country and
attacking the institution the monarchy
is racist I think I think actually I
think she is she is what I would call a
race beta if she doesn't produce hard
evidence to support these incendiary
claims she becomes a race beta
exploiting racism and the issue of
racism to act as a kind of protective
shield around her and to make herself
extremely rich and famous as a
professional victim I've spent more time
in Sussex than Megan and Harry have in
the last two weeks so actually a month
but um they're never there but they've
got these titles which are given to them
that's probably all I mean about they
trade off Duke and Duchess as Sussex the
Royals to make themselves incredibly
rich and I just I do wonder if there's a
point where Charles goes actually you
can't do that anymore it'd be
unprecedented but why wouldn't he yeah
but I think it's kind of irrelevant I
mean no one really cares about the
titles if you strip them with the titles
there's still Harry and Megan they'd
still be equally famous they wouldn't be
acting as members of the royal family
yeah I don't think they go around acting
as members of the role they do all the
paperwork all the letter headings is all
due from the office of the Duchess of
Sussex almost nonsense she calls herself
a princess on her podcast little girls
have got to make a real princess you're
not a princess she's not princess anyway
uh but they do it quite deliberately to
fuel the interest from commercial
entities and really the interest is
based on them trashing their family I
mean without that I'm not sure what
we're interested in we don't want to
hear their woke homilies about life do
we so I'm not sure how this all plays
out but it's a mess and Charles may have
to deal with it I think we're good
evening from London welcome to Piers
Morgan on censored today Harry and Megan
torched what little was left of their
relationship with the royal family and
what little was less frankly of their
own reputations last week was mostly
sycophantic this latest installment was
downright seditious Prince Harry malls
his own brother
accuses his father the new king of being
a liar even as a dig in his late great
grandmother the Queen the standing by
and doing nothing
they're all families directly accused of
destroying two of its own to protect
itself
and I don't know where it all stops all
this
where does it end we got the book and
then we've got the interview circuit and
until it goes on
it's all apparently a dark plot by
Britain and the Royals to smear the poor
defenseless vulnerable sussexes
trickery treachery hypocrisy and if
there's one conclusion to draw from the
final installment of the Netflix series
is that Prince Harry surely as now a
traitor to the country that he once
served